this episode is sponsored by ren a
website where you calculate your carbon
footprint and you can also sign up to
make a monthly contribution to offset
your carbon footprint or support
rainforest protection projects
[Music]
when you are in the world of the
microbes it does not seem necessary to
think of the largest land mammal on
earth
what could elephants possibly have to do
with a ciliate when you say this out
loud any potential connection seems
dubious at best however if you look at
the deleptus you see an elongated moving
body one that seems like it's made up
entirely of snout like an elephant's
trunk disembodied and shrunk down so
that it can survive all on its own
but unlike the elephant the leptus is no
gentle giant it isn't moving around
because it wants to play or drink water
no the deleptus is waving around because
it is loaded with toxins and it wants to
put them to good use
now this may be surprising given its
general blob like appearance but the
leptus's body is divided into two
distinct regions the proboscis and the
trunk
but the trunk on the deleptus is not
actually the elephant trunk-like part of
the organism the trunk is in this case
more like the trunk of a tree it's the
base for the rest of the leptus's body
the proboscis is the snout the part that
extends to the rest of the micro cosmos
and examines it looking for something to
eat
and interestingly where the proboscis
and the trunk connect lies the
delectus's mouth a cavity lined with
hair like cilia that continues down the
length of the proboscis the leptus can
use these cilia to generate currents in
the water that carry food to its oral
cavity you can imagine it a bit like if
your arm hairs could stir up the air
around you and levitate the snack in
your hand all the way to your mouth
which now i'm thinking about it sounds
amazing
but before the cilia can work their
magic the dileptus has to catch its food
and that's unfortunate for the
spurostomum at the bottom left corner it
does not know that on the other side of
that piece of debris is a predator that
one scientist called the king of beasts
among the ciliated protozoa with an
appetite that is quote insatiable the
dileptus is not a subtle lying and
weight kind of predator it's always
moving always seeking and when its
proboscis makes contact with the
spirostomum it grabs a chunk of its body
almost instantly
the spirostomum is large and nimble and
pulls away quickly as if it's been stung
but it leaves behind a tasty morsel of
itself which the leptus draws in until
it's close enough to open wide and eat
[Music]
and from its safe distance away the
spirostoma may not be whole again yet
but it is at least out of reach of the
dileptus and of its proboscis and its
hundreds of toxicists you can actually
see those toxicists here when we look at
the proboscis with a thousand times
magnification
and while the proboscis's movement
through the water may seem like a
chaotic mess of twisting left and right
and up and down there is a surprising
order to it all driven by the placement
of those toxic cellular weapons
the leptus has to move in a way that
lets it immediately attack its prey upon
contact but its proboscis is only lined
with toxicists on one side the side that
leads to the oral cavity so it always
sweeps its proboscis with its toxicists
facing whatever
is about to be swept and when it's done
moving in one direction that eleptus
rotates its proboscis and sweeps it in
the other direction again this is also
that when the dileptus finally hits
something it won't just make contact it
will unload needles full of toxins into
whatever it has made contact with
to learn a bit more about how these
toxins work in one experiment scientists
filled a fluid with the material coming
from the leptus's toxins they then
placed some paramecium into the fluid to
see how they would respond
they did not respond well
immediately the paramecium tried to
mount their own defenses by releasing
their own harpooning trichicists now
that might have worked against an actual
dileptus pitting ciliate against cilia
as they poke each other for survival but
in this experiment with the toxins
permeating the fluid the best the
paramecium could hope for was to delay
the inevitable
to use its trickiest as a temporary
fence until eventually it emerged to its
own death
now that is an extreme situation one
that a paramecium would probably not
actually find itself in were it anywhere
else but in a lab fortunately for
paramecium we do not live in a world
full of dileptus toxin fluid those
toxins are kept safely packaged within
the organisms themselves waiting for
their designated time
which does lead us to a final question
one that we do not have an answer for
but that we like thinking about
nonetheless
we've seen the leptus as a solitary
organism and we've also seen it in
groups with others of its kind
but how
how does an organism that is so simple
so reactive so toxic how is it able to
just casually entwine itself with others
of its own kind how can they gather
without immediately all jabbing each
other to death
well
we don't know but it means that there
must be more to the release of toxicists
than just the simple mechanical stimulus
of touch
that there must be some sort of
recognition that makes it possible for
two delectuses to know each other
you might even call it chemistry
now we don't know the underlying signs
and signals that make that recognition
possible but what drove this mutually
assured safety may have actually been
something selfish imagine for a moment
that the palm of your hand was covered
in toxic needles and every time you
touched your own body your palm tore off
a piece of it you would probably not
last long as an organism you would need
some kind of way to tell your palm that
the thing it is touching is in fact the
body it belongs to and to not try and
damage it the same may have been true
for the ancestors of deleptus and other
organisms that have toxicits they may
have kept accidentally hurting
themselves over and over often beyond
repair until evolution provided a new
path one where they would be able to
recognize themselves and perhaps
eventually even others of their own kind
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
ren for sponsoring this episode of
journey to the micro cosmos ren is a
website where you can calculate your
carbon footprint and then offset it by
funding projects that plant trees and
provide clean burning fuel and cook
stoves for refugees in uganda we will
need a lot of different approaches to
stop the climate crisis and this is one
way that you can learn more about your
carbon contribution and take some action
you can answer a few questions about
your lifestyle so that you can see what
your carbon footprint is and they'll
also show you ways to start reducing it
now no one can reduce their carbon
footprint to zero but using ren you can
offset what you have left once you sign
up you'll receive updates from the tree
planting rainforest protection and other
projects you support and we have
partnered with ren to protect an extra
10 acres of rainforest for the first 100
people who sign up using the link in our
description
there are now a bunch of names that are
coming up on the screen these are our
patreon patrons if you like what we do
here at journey to the micro cosmos
these are some of the folks that you can
thank and the good news is that you can
become one of them all you have to do is
go to patreon.com journey2micro and
become a patreon patron if you want to
see more from our master of microscopes
james weiss you can check out jam and
germs on instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's probably a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you